it doesn't take a statistician to figure
out that men dominate the stands of
Qatar 2022 just as they have at previous
tournaments FIFA says at the 2018 World
Cup about 25 percent of the spectators
were women it expects the same this year
[Music]
woman also want to check it out Qatar
ranks as one of the safest countries in
the world according to several lists you
feel very protected you know the
security everywhere and like as a woman
you don't I don't think you can feel
like a difference between if you were a
man like everyone is safe I made friends
with people around me the Muslim country
also prohibited the sale of alcohol in
and around the stadiums we've been in
England in matches and you cannot
imagine with alcohol what what they do
so yeah it made the big difference FIFA
debuted a human rights volunteer program
at Qatar 2022 more than 100 volunteers
are positioned at every match and fan
Zone they're here to observe engage with
fans and workers and record any
grievances such as sexual harassment
discrimination and disability access
issues
FIFA is hoping the program raises
awareness and ensures a better Fan
Experience you actually have your rights
because most of the time people feel
like okay that's it and they're just
like okay accept whatever it is but
actually it's not because you have the
rights you have the right to speak you
have the right to express you have the
rights to be a human
lgbtq fans and their supporters who wore
rainbow t-shirts or carried Flags into
the stadiums in Qatar might dispute that
there is now a means to formally file a
complaint with FIFA it plans to share
Lessons Learned with the center for
sport and human rights off the pitch the
goal is to create a human rights program
that could be used for other sporting
events such as the Olympics Natasha
ganim Al Jazeera El core Qatar